so in this paper we ask the following
question when you invest in energy
efficient strategies what sort of
rebound effects can we anticipate and
what are the consequences for policies a
rebound effect occurs when we take
action to reduce energy consumption but
we end up with less savings than what we
anticipate for example we can reduce
lighting energy consumption in Howard
houses by 75% by installing more
efficient light bulbs if we leave the
lights on for the same period of time
will indeed save 75% of the lighting
electricity consumption however since
the lighting service has effectively
become cheaper we may decide to leave
the lights on for a longer period of
time why not we're saving energy and
money at the same time this will result
in having less savings from electricity
than what was anticipated this is called
a direct rebound effect and now what if
we actually use the savings from that
energy efficiency intervention to travel
to Europe or to buy goods and services
that we're not purchasing in the first
place this may increase our carbon or
energy footprint and so this is called
the indirect rebound effect so how much
is the rebound effect
well the studies vary widely with some
estimates as low as 0 or as high as 60%
or more depending on the region of
analysis the in use under study and the
time period of analysis for example and
why is looking at rebound effects
important well because if we do not
account for rebound effects we may be
overstating the potential impact from
energy efficiency measures and so that
may have consequences for policy design
this makes it challenging to determine
whether states are meeting their energy
efficiency resource standards what are
our energy efficiency resource standards
energy efficiency resource standards
require utilities to reduce energy
consumption through energy efficiency
programs 20 states have these standards
and 7 other states have similar goals
reaching overhaul a
hundred million customers so are the
states measuring their progress towards
those goals accurately in this work we
seek to answer that same question so how
did we determine the indirect rebound
effects in this work so in this work we
couple a neoclassical economics model of
consumer behavior with an input-output
model of the economy that provides the
life cycle emissions and energy
consumption for all the goods and
services in the economy so our analysis
provides a first-order estimate of
indirect rebound effects we also show
how those differ by states as function
of carbon emissions factors consumption
patterns and so forth so what are the
annual direct and indirect rebound
effects for each of the 50 states so the
first step in assessing the magnitude of
those rebound effects is to establish a
baseline so our first step was to
compute the household carbon footprints
for each of the 50 states we found that
the carbon footprints for each of the 50
states differs quite substantially the
figure highlights that the carbon
footprints differ widely from state
estates during particular to differences
in Grid emissions factors and also on
household patterns of consumption we
then simulated the rebound effects in
the figure you see the magnitude of the
rebound effects and potential savings
from a 10% improvement in energy
efficiency in electricity the white bars
correspond to the potential savings from
that intervention the color bars
correspond to the rebound effects you'll
notice that the color bars are really
small in comparison to the white bars
overall we find that the rebound effects
are small however those differ quite
substantially from state to state and
then can be as little as six percents in
West Virginia and as high as 40% in
California so after all this work what
are our recommendations for the policy
makers so first of all policy makers
should assess the magnitude of direct
and indirect rebound effects in
particular when they are aiming
for the goals for their energy
efficiency resource standards in case
those are large they should be
considering in the policy analysis the
presence of rebound effects highlights
the importance of complementing carat
sorts of incentives with sticks such as
carbon prices or carbon standards and
finally we find that overall rebound
effects are small so they should not put
into question energy efficiency policies
you